I came into a black radio actually my
father was a it was a big distract a so
he he coerced me into reading the news
on the air doing his during his radio
ships before my voice even changed when
I got into the military in 1970 i
actually had no experience in doing
anything worthwhile or that could get
one paid except jumping out of airplanes
and talking on the radio so so that's
when I entered radio in 1970 there was a
wonderful period the the black the black
radio format had exploded all over all
across the country by that time they
were now hundreds of black radio
stations but because we had just
experienced the 60s and and that
wonderful period of of people in motion
those radio stations people demanded of
those radio stations that they be
accountable to that newly awakens
community and so every radio station
virtually every black oriented radio
station in the country was compelled to
hire full-time at least one newscaster
this was a whole new core of news people
that didn't even exist five years before
all of a sudden there are hundreds of
radio news people at stations that
didn't even exist five years before who
are trying to figure out how do we serve
the community and and what what occurred
was a a beautiful synergy between a
movement which still was vital and
energetic and a bunch of young
broadcasters whose job whose
self-assigned job was to report on the
movement in that process new leadership
which comes up all the time in the
community
found found themselves with with a voice
on the air through a medium that was
speaking directly to their people not a
general format medium that's speaking to
everybody but black radio that was
speaking to your community and that
became a megaphone for our black
conversation that that had never existed
before it it unleashed or empowered a
whole new layer generation of leadership
to to take on projects that they might
have not taken on before without the the
the presence of newscasters on the
medium that their friends and family and
neighbors were listening to paying
attention to them and treating them as
black leaders black radio then became an
incubator for emerging black leadership
and it was a wonderful and very bright
vibrant time but as radio consolidated
as things always do under capitalism a
black radio also consolidated and began
shedding its newsrooms in 1973 in
Washington DC three black oriented radio
stations fielded 21 reporters that's a
black radio press corps of its own in
that city and and much the same was
happening and big and small cities all
across the country in Washington DC
today there are six black oriented radio
stations together they filled only for
reporters the black radio is no longer
an incubator for black leadership and I
believe that these decades of near of
deterioration and now near extinction of
black radio news has contributed to the
to the leadership crisis that we have in
black America who is the leader who's
using the leaders you see what I'm
saying the incubator was gone and now
the discourse is entirely in the hands
of a corporate media which is also white
even if it employs are the black folks
it's still a white corporate medium
my take on this is also rather different
than my colleagues I don't see this new
media as being in any way a real
counterbalance to the hedge emoni of the
corporate media black black agenda
report for example reaches twenty five
thousand readers per week per issue they
are very smart people we chose them and
they chose us and they're movers and
shakers and and we think we we do as
good a job as we can of influencing
their thought processes however there's
no way that that that can in any way
compete with the major broadcasters who
also who also control most of what we
call new media they see so the decline
of broadcast television does not mean
that the corporate voice is in decline
it means the corporate voice is more is
has infiltrated many other areas of of
media establishing its homogenizing
standards including new media
if I couldn't if I could use an example
which i think is a telling one it
certainly opened my eyes from from hip
hop in 1987 i co-founded the first rap
music syndication on commercial radio
called wrap it up eventually we had 66
stations this was a another wonderful
period in black culture all of these
young people who had found a vehicle for
their own cultural and political
expression doing their own thing through
about five or six independent labels
almost all of them in New York and it
took off like like wildfire the the big
labels looked at it as corporations do
to see how they could get in it took him
a couple of years but by about nineteen
ninety they began buying up the the
original independent hip hop labels and
preparing to make their big move they
were going to to own hip-hop but they
were rather confused as corporate types
are with new phenomenon barely there
these were new numbers and they didn't
understand them then in 1991 one of the
one of the big labels did a study and
what they found was something kind of
amazing they found that the most active
consumers of hip hop were 11 and 12 year
olds that's called tweens in the
business these these are these are not
yet even teenagers they saw that that
that was a fantastic figure no no other
genre of music had had garnered a core
listenership that was that young even
R&B was 15 16 17 years old but here they
had 12 and 13 year-olds it was it was
this as if they were struck by lightning
they say
we will take over this medium and and
tailor the product for what we now know
because of our study is the most active
consuming group and from that moment on
they made rap product pre juvenile now
what did you vanaya like 12 12 and 13
year olds like boys as well as girls
they like to curse remember when you
were that age there's those those Chris
words rolling off your tongue it's
almost it's it's it's a very sensual
feeling and so and so the their product
was peppered with gratuitous profanity
in fact they they they began bringing in
very young groups that were foul of
mouth because that's what the study told
them these 12 and 13 year olds would
like there's another characteristic of
the 12 and 13 year old especially the
boys but also the girls especially the
boys however and that's misogyny 11 12
year old boys don't know how to deal
with girls and so they act like they
hate them so there's a kind of of
juvenile misogyny that is a part of that
period of human development the
corporation's understood that too and so
they saturated their product with with
misogynist lyrics so here we have
profanity and misogyny that is
industrially fed into the music I can't
tell you how many times these young
people would be sitting at my kitchen
table after interviews that we would do
with them almost in tears because the
the labels that they were working with
were pressuring them to get Street or 11
young female artists she was about 16
years old actually broke down in tears
and said they're trying to make me into
a whore they're trying to make me into a
whore and they were
well we have to break the back of
corporate power that's the project for
all of humanity we can't solve any of
the world's problems except through
human collaboration and the big obstacle
in our way is corporate power corporate
power of course runs the United States
corporate power and imperial power the
same thing here so in that kind of light
then the difficulties posed to to our
culture by profane and misogynist rap
lyrics kind of pales in comparison
doesn't it but it's all about breaking